hace unos meses me encontraba en nueva
york haciendo una certificación en un
taller de masturbación femenina era un
grupo muy diverso mujeres de muchas
edades diversas también y en un minuto
nos encontrábamos en un espacio muy
íntimo en el cual había que mostrar las
vulvas
y esta mujer tenía más de 70 años se
sienta abre sus piernas y se pone a
llorar
la directora del programa le pregunta te
pasa algo te sientes incómoda están
nerviosa y ella le dice no
es que hace un rato una chica joven
abrió sus piernas y vi que su vulva era
igual a la mía
esta mujer se pasó 70 años y un poco más
creyendo que tenía una deformación en
sus labios mayores
qué es lo que les quiero invitar hoy día
primero que nada a cuestionarse todo
todo lo que han escuchado lo que piensan
o lo que sienten en relación a la
masturbación femenina y en relación a su
genitalidad porque porque siempre hay
algo más que aprender no porque él o yo
que yo tenga sea malo o errado puede que
sí puede que me frene puede que me
limite y al cuestionarme qué hago ahí me
abro un campo gigantesco gigantesco
hacia lo desconocido
no hay nada más maravilloso que cuando
hablamos de placer de sexualidad de
identidad sexual que lo desconocido y la
masturbación y la masturbación femenina
tiene esa característica en particular
ya que ha sido un espacio desconocido
por muchas mujeres la sexualidad y la
masturbación puede femenina en
particular tiene la característica o las
creencias asociadas de castración
que se debe dar espontáneamente
2 que si no se dio espontáneamente se va
a dar con otra persona 3 a veces está
asociado a demasiada soledad
que es malo que es sucio especialmente
cuando somos pequeñas criamos niñas
jóvenes adolescentes que no saben
vincularse con este placer no saben lo
que es ser un ser sexuado y la
masturbación femenina necesita de que
todas nosotras como mujeres nos
transformemos en seres sexuados ahora
como hacemos eso desde el cuerpo
en el occidente somos personas muy
pensantes y creemos que todo parte desde
el cerebro y de ahí hacia abajo la
sexualidad y las turbas y la
masturbación tiene una característica
propia del cuerpo
y el cuerpo es una estructura sagrada se
nos olvida que es una estructura sagrada
que la habita una deidad yo soy mi
cuerpo yo soy una deidad
yo me adorno yo me visto yo me cuido
y para que esta deidad se transforme en
una deidad sexuada
tengo que trabajar hacia allá y para eso
tengo que estudiar me
primero me cuestiono veo lo que no se ve
o lo que no siento para poder estudiar
me
cuando hablamos de masturbación femenina
hablamos de placer
y hoy día no quiero hablar de orgasmo
quiero dejar el orgasmo de lado y por
qué porque suele suceder que se busca la
masturbación con un propósito y ese
propósito es excitarme para tener un
orgasmo
y qué sucede en el medio me pregunto yo
qué pasa con el proceso del placer
qué pasa si decidimos que el orgasmo
queda fuera de la masturbación
y lo que aparece es el cuerpo
un cuerpo que si no tiene propiedad y
seguridad
no puede abarcar todos los espacios que
como mujer necesitamos la seguridad no
solamente es para la sexualidad el
cuerpo no solamente está puesto para la
sexualidad el cuerpo está puesto para el
trabajo para dormir para levantarme en
la mañana ducharme tomarme un café
entonces cuando tomo este cuerpo y le
doy propiedad y le doy fuerza y lo
estudio empieza a aparecer la seguridad
que es propia de la identidad trabajar
la identidad en cada una de nosotras es
fundamental porque nos ayuda a que es a
crecer a evolucionar y hacer autónomos e
independientes nada más maravilloso en
la actualidad la posibilidad de ser
autónomo e independiente por ende
diferente y mi sexualidad y mi
masturbación tiene esa misma
característica yo puedo hacer de mi
masturbación un proceso de placer que
incluya lo que yo necesite pero para eso
debo estudiar me
estudiar mis pensamientos mis placeres
mi sensorialidad como este cuerpo se
comporta cuando quiere descansar
cuando quiere recibir un cariño y cuando
quiere erotizar sé
ahora una de las dificultades en este
proceso que nos encontramos es que las
mujeres tenemos un vínculo con nuestro
cuerpo y con nuestra genitalidad que a
veces es compleja
a veces nos da pudor nos da vergüenza
aunque estemos en soledad yo puedo estar
sola en la cocina en el living en el
baño o en la cama da lo mismo donde yo
quiera apropiarme de mi cuerpo pero
cuando aparece esta característica de
tocarse de sentirse a muchas de nuestras
mujeres nos da pudor
nos da vergüenza mirarnos
nos da vergüenza tocarnos nuestros
genitales nos da vergüenza ver qué color
tienen cómo huele
yo puedo sentir como huele mi muñeca el
perfume que me estoy echando mi ropa
pero cuantas de ustedes puede decir que
sabe cómo huelen sus genitales sus
fluidos
entonces el vínculo con el cuerpo y la
identidad sexual es un trabajo que
primero tenemos que separar de la
estructura del deber ser porque si no
nuestros genitales y nuestra sexualidad
femenina queda cerrada
principalmente a un vínculo con otra
persona y ahí se pone todo muy pobre y
no queremos que nuestra sexualidad sea
pobre queremos que sea rica que sea
diversa a mí me gusta describir la
masturbación femenina como el chocolate
que tengo en el velador o esa parte mía
íntima privada que se maneja de vez en
cuando y sé que está ahí
algunas tienen guardada en el
refrigerador a algo pero cada una de
nosotras tiene ciertos placeres y en
ciertos antojos que conoce si la
masturbación la introduzco dentro de esa
área se transforma en un goce a
descubrir un nuevo chocolate un nuevo
helado un nuevo yogurt con nuevas
sensaciones
ahora muchas de mis pacientes me
preguntan bueno y cómo lo hago
porque yo no puedo forzar a alguien a ir
a tocarse los genitales a comprarse un
vibrador
no no puedo forzar a alguien así anda y
toca te anda y excitante
y ahí es donde viene una frase que a mí
me encanta que es el material erótico la
responsabilidad de cada una de nosotras
es ver cuál va a ser mi propio material
erótico que mero tiza a mí una canción
exponerme pasearme desnuda por el living
que me empieza a sentir que mi cuerpo
el propio mío porque si no me empieza a
dar vergüenza tocarme
la crema por ejemplo cuántas mujeres acá
se demoran más de 10 minutos en echarse
crema yo podría decir dos o tres pero
estos gestos donde todos lo hacemos
rápido donde nos limpiamos rápido nos
lavamos rápido no nos damos tiempo para
lavarnos el pelo el pelo suele ser como
un espacio de la mujer es el hoy me lavo
el pelo me demoro
y a mí me gustaría que las mujeres
dijeran hoy me doy una tina hoy voy a
cocinar me algo hoy voy a ambientar me
voy a preparar un espacio para poder
masturbarme
como me lavo el pelo en 20 minutos me
masturbo en 20 minutos
no buscando el orgasmo sino que buscando
este proceso donde entra todas mis
fantasías mi juego o sea la lectura sea
la película sea una polola del colegio o
un novio por ahí sea los colores de mi
misma
cada una de ustedes debe educarse en
buscar y construir este material erótico
entonces una vez que tengo identificado
sensorialmente qué cosas me pueden
gustar bien el cuerpo como hago presente
el cuerpo es una de las grandes cuestión
antes como dejo los pensamientos que
intervienen el placer erótico fuera
y tenemos ejercicios básicos ejercicios
sencillos les voy a mostrar uno
una de las formas de bajar al cuerpo es
activar las zonas de los músculos
gruesos entonces les invito en sus casas
a ponerse de rodillas activar los
glúteos la zona baja del abdomen y
contra en la musculatura
moviéndose adelante y hacia atrás hace
que yo tenga que concentrarme en un
cuerpo porque lo estoy activando lo
estoy ejercitando si a eso le empieza a
sumar olores disfrutes placeres fantasía
sueños y una mano
y una mano no que vaya directo a mis
genitales una mano que empieza a sentir
este cuerpo y empiezo a diferenciar qué
sensaciones me llevan a dormirme qué
caricias me relajan y cuáles me
comienzan a excitar y una vez que
encuentro estas que pueden llegar a
excitar me empiezo a sostenerlas
a sostenerlas y por supuesto que sumó
tocarme los genitales lo cual puede ser
por fuera de la ropa dentro de la ropa
no se presionen a buscar un proceso como
supuestamente es no lleguen a tocar su
clítoris directamente toque lo por
alrededor muevan sus labios
échense lubricante rubriquen si ustedes
mismas el punto cuando hablamos de
masturbación femenina es estudien sé
la única que se puede hacer cargo de su
placer son ustedes mismas
y por supuesto que después nos sirve al
encontrarnos con otra persona
pero primero el punto cero soy yo yo en
el aquí y el ahora
por lo tanto hoy día el mensaje que les
quiero dejar es cuestionen sé todo lo
que saben vuelvan a cuestionarlo no
busquen el orgasmo en una masturbación
quédense en el proceso un proceso puede
ser un ratito en la mañana mientras me
hago el café un ratito en la tarde
mientras me duermo y al tercer día me
masturbo y al cuarto logro el orgasmo o
logro el orgasmo al tiro y después me
paso a otro espacio de placer movilicen
esta estructura desarme las
y apropiarse de sus cuerpos desde lo más
sencillo un ejercicio un olor y un
descanso
[Aplausos]